Hey guys, what's up? My name is Peter
Sudara, so my name is Yoshi, Sodexo,
and today we're going to be
playing some candid confession.
Yoshi. Hi. Peter's
miss. Meet you. Meet you
face like,
oh,
is this not the dating one
dose and stuff like that?
Man, we already had going on.
What is your relationship to each other?
We're brothers. Yes, and I'm a better one.
The better one.
I've known him all his life.
He hasn't known me all my life though.
I've known him all my life,
so technically you haven't
known me all your life. Oh,
me and Yoshi are pretty open book.
We know each other very well or so.
We think we're still,
we think so.
I'm kind of scared saying
that we're going to go.
Never have I ever hit on
one of your female friends?
Three, two, one? Nope.
Nope. Oh yeah. Well I,
I know you have. Every time I tell him,
I was like, hey, I liked this girl.
Wait, no, you know that's true.
That's true. Your first girlfriend,
who wasn't going that I told him
that he thought she was cute.
I didn't know you were going for her work.
You? I don't know. I don't know. Thanks.
You
never have I ever blamed
something I did on you.
Ready? Three, two, one.
We do this all the time.
I feel like our dynamic and
brothers is almost as twins.
Like you do something bad, you
blame it on me. I do something bad.
I blame it on you.
And then eventually we realize we should
just keep it to ourselves because I
know another one of us gets
in trouble. You know it.
I made us a lot closer as friends.
It's not like that's happened
in the recent years, not as TMI
love you like, okay. As a child,
as a child,
like maybe like three or four.
I remember peeing on
the floor on accident,
like I couldn't hold it and I was so
scared of getting in trouble and I blame
that on your sheet because obviously as
a child you don't think about that stuff.
You're just like, oh my pants
are wet. But he's right there.
So that could be him like you don't know.
I know. Oh my God, we were
such dumb kids who saying we,
hold on,
I didn't do that.
I can't actually remember what I've done.
Use a big brain farts on me.
Oh yeah, totally. Yeah. That's
like, I guess kids are easy.
Never have I ever cried in front of you.
Oh, three, two, one
all the time.
We're emotional crybaby.
Both of us tears everywhere.
I mean, watching movies,
watching movies up.
You weren't like in all the floor.
Very sensitive dudes like we have.
We talk about our feelings a lot.
So a lot of times we'll argue and get
to a point of even tears. Tears. Yeah.
They were arguing and
yeah.
Never have I ever been jealous
because of a girl you've been with.
All right. Three, two, one. No, no.
Yeah. Somebody, it's like off, off limits.
I can't even look at that person.
It's weird.
Like even that's also why I went like
the girls in the friends thing. I mean,
obviously it didn't matter to you.
So, uh, and just kidding. You know, I,
you know, I actually had no idea. Right.
I don't realize it until I
was older and I was like, Hey,
I was just totally harmonious that
you guys would have been so bad again.
Oh my gosh, yes. Holy Crap. Thank
you for saving me from that.
Yes or no. Sometimes I question, I dunno.
Sometimes I question if what I'm
doing has any meaning or value.
Okay. Uh, yeah, three, two, one
definitely.
Can I do that because
partially, no. Absolutely. So
that's a, that's a yes. Okay.
Then I'll just take your head like,
okay.
Even if you thought about it a little bit,
but if you don't question it,
then how do you know if all you're doing
is the right thing? Right. I agree.
I think if you're, if you're questioning
it and you're still doing it,
that's why it went nowhere.
The rest, but the same time.
Because at first I was like, yes.
Sometimes I think about that,
but then I always come to the conclusion
of like, of course, yeah, there's,
there's meaningful it.
That's why I do it because at the end
of the day you got to realize that like
what you're doing can make a difference.
And as long as it makes a difference
in one person's life, dude. Yeah. Done.
And if you're not looking at it in that
way, why are you doing it? Fame. Money.
You're right.
I guess never have I ever felt
jealous of your accomplishments.
All right. Okay. Three, two, one.
I mean,
let's be honest,
it's like when you first got power
rangers and I auditioned hard for it.
Like with Donald Trump,
jr knew how hard I was working for that.
So I told you that though. That's, I
think that's the main thing with us.
Like both of us have spoken to each other.
Like if I'm feeling jealous about it,
I'll let you know.
You've known when I've been jealous of
stuff to like social media, social media.
Yeah. Yours was definitely way more at
the top. At the beginning I was very like,
dude, I am nothing right
now. I'm a nobody. I was so
used to it buddy growing up.
Oh you're Yoshi is a little brother.
And then it became,
I'm Peter's brother and I was like, what
is going on? And I was like, I can't,
I can't ask him for help because I
want to just do my own social media.
But then when I was like, you know, I was
like, I'm just going to ask. I'm like,
hey man, like what do I do with this whole
thing? And you were like, here, put this,
try this on with this. And I'm
like, oh yeah, that's cool.
I would never think to put
those two things together.
And now my social media is good and
it's because of me asking for your help.
Before I was like, no, he's not going
to help me. He's, he wants this for him.
I put it in my head that he wants to
be the guy who's like, oh, oh, you're,
you're Peter's brother.
I put that on him. I do.
We never want to call him Peter's brother.
Just kidding. Go happens again,
please let me know. Absolutely.
That's what we do now. You know? Oh
man, you mean versus the world, right.
It's ups and down. Of
course it is. I shut up.
Never have I ever told you why I love you.
Okay.
Three, two, one. I don't really have,
I think maybe if anything it's, it
would be more red for me. I don't know.
I don't know. I don't think we
have ever really talked about that.
We just kind of like new cause I mean
it's all this stuff that we talk about,
all of this, you know, we're
always supporting each other.
We're trying to pull each other
even when it gets down bad. Yeah.
It's like you're mad at me because
you love me and can see me do better.
You're an amazing big brother. I
know. Yeah. No, you really are.
You really are you? I, I
can't, I am so blessed.
It sounds like the most basic compliment.
I can't sit in there the way you're one
of the most genuine dudes I've ever met.
I am not that good of a dude to you.
I feel like I screwed up with you a
lot and yet you still look up to me and
that's a big reason why I love you.
You have been the one that pushed
me to become the way that I am.
It's funny. I mean, I got that from
you. I think you did. I didn't do that.
And you say all this stuff about me and
my action, whatever, but me getting Cota,
was you seeing something in that character
that I could do? And also yourself.
Sure. You just put an image
in my head and that was it.
It wasn't like it will be a director
and that's what I believe you can.
And, and, and I'm ready to be
by your side when that happens.
Thanks for being good friend
and brother. Ah, I got you.
No, I don't want to do this again. No.
Oh, hi jubilee fam. I'm Ian. I'm Taylor.
Thanks so much for watching guys.
We always appreciate it so much.
Where'd you please leave us a nice comment
below telling us your favorite parts.
Subscribe up here.
Watch more videos over there and join
our family because we are on a mission to
inspire some change maker.
See you guys later.
So.